the day was punctuated by video much of
it which had never been seen before much
of it security footage from actually
inside the capitol building itself
senators
could only watch on in horror as they
saw how police officers
were overwhelmed how they sent frantic
radio messages urging for help how they
stood against
the violent tide that swept towards them
threatening to challenge the results of
the presidential election
at the very heart of american democracy
the evidence will show that he clearly
incited the january 6th insurrection
it will show that donald trump
surrendered his role
as commander-in-chief and became the
inciter
in chief that mob was summoned
assembled and incited
by the former president of the united
states donald trump
and he did that because he wanted to
stop the transfer of power so that
he could retain power
this was never about pursuing legitimate
claims he was saying anything he could
to trigger and anger his base so that
they would fight like hell
to overturn a legitimate election
this violent attack was not planned in
secret
the insurgents believed that they were
doing the duty
of their president
[Applause]
the democrat impeachment managers also
highlighted donald trump's criticism of
vice president mike pence
how he didn't have the courage to do his
job and then they showed the video
of how close the crowd came to the vice
president
and the awful consequences that may have
followed
this next security video shows that
evacuation
you can see vice president pence and his
family
quickly move down the stairs the vice
president turns around
as the rioters reached the top of the
stairs
they were within 100 feet of where the
vice president was sheltering with his
family
and they were just a feet away from one
of the doors
to this chamber where many of you
remained
at that time
[Applause]
vice president pence was threatened with
death
by the president's supporters because he
rejected
president trump's demand that he
overturned the election
the first critical hour and a half of
this bloody attack
donald trump tweeted his rally speech
and did nothing else
senators you've seen all the evidence so
far
and this is clear on january 6
president trump left everyone
in this capital for dead
the democrats may have moved some
republican senators with
the audio and the video that they played
today but it's still unlikely they'll
get enough votes to convict donald trump
but what they have done
is lay the narrative of donald trump's
final days in office
and the assault on the capital on
january the sixth
twenty twenty one well jeff houser is a
lawyer and executive director of the
revolving door project at the center for
economic and policy research he says the
evidence presented
is damning the strength of their case is
commendable
they have distilled a complex event
into a format that is uh easily
understood
and i think if there were a secret
ballot
uh they would get overwhelming support
in the senate
and they have done as good a job as is
possible
in making the determination of
this trial not about the democrats but
about the republicans
the republican party is now on trial
the republican party can prove itself a
meaningful part
of a democratic society by voting to
end donald trump's influence in the
party and to convict him
or they can retain donald trump as their
leader in fact even if not entitled and
i think then
democrats will have their work cut out
for them but they will realize that the
republican party
is not a party with which you can
cooperate if you believe in
small d democracy and the rule of law uh
donald trump had been
weaving toward this event going back to
june of 2020 he'd been laying the
groundwork
that if he has not declared the victor
it had to have been
due to uh theft but we now learn
today that he had a phone call with
senator tuberville of alabama
and heard about the duress that mike
pence his vice president
and the senate was under so we now know
we have a
chronology of when did trump know and
what what did he know and when did he
know it
and then his failure to act for another
couple of
hours is incredibly damning and
underscores
the idea that what was occurring was not
against his wishes but was in fact an
advancement of his wishes